Welcome back to the world transformed we are
socialist Think Tank and we are going to be
talking today about the cost of living crisis this
is the big one this is something that I think on
the left we really need to address because the
mainstream media narrative about what's causing
the cost of living crisis and the solutions to
the cost of living crisis simply aren't being
explained very well at all they're confusing
people to be honest they make literally no
sense because in my view they're trying to cover
something up they're trying to tell us a story
that's different from what reality is so today
we're going to explore the reality of the cost
of living crisis I'll introduce myself I'm Paul
Daley I'm a presenter at socialist Think Tank
and now I'm going to pass you to my amazing guests
I'm going to start off with Sarah from the biggest
Union Sarah would you like to say something
about yourself tell us who you are yes I'm um
around it time and understand
so like for me that the important thing is
you've you've done the job where you're with
your workplace representative were you like a
shop steward in the union there I think that's
so important for a general secretary to have
that background in really dealing with the
day-to-day stuff so you will really understand
how people are living their lives and also I
suppose having worked in a shop you get to
see like all the different aspects of society
and people coming through the doors and that
kind of thing is that a fair assumption yeah
um and also we've got Gary Gary can you tell us
a little bit about yourself because we're very
excited to have you on also uh yeah my name's Gary
Stevenson uh I'm an economist mainly inequality uh
the big thing for me is my back because I was I
was a Trader I worked as a Trader after the 2008
crisis I worked for Citibank and I became City
bank's most profitable Trader in the world by
betting that because you wouldn't fix inequality
that crisis would last for a very long time and
have very bad impact on our economy so um I did
that for a few years I bet that the economy would
never recover and I made a lot of money doing
it and after a couple years you start to think
maybe I should try and stop this from happening
so uh I quit that job which the bank wasn't too
happy about I went and did a degree in economics
at Oxford and uh that was though to push guys in
capes in working in castles and I think this is
probably not where change is going to come from
so I quit that and I started to sort of try and
speak publicly so now I've got a YouTube called
Gary's economics where I try and basically
explain to people how serious inequality
Is wealth inequality the effect it has on the
economy the effect it has on ordinary families
the big aim of the YouTube is basically to make a
space where we talk about economics in a way that
is accessible and easy for just ordinary people
to understand um and it's super important now
because coven has seen the biggest and fastest
ever increase in inequality in the country
um obviously the budget yesterday will see
another massive increase inequality and um
yeah it's really important that people understand
how that's going to affect themselves people get a
chance to talk about it yeah definitely and from
your point of view do you think like the economy
is deliberately cloudy you know so they'll they'll
use words that ordinary people might zone out on
and you know they might not really engage with
economics and think Ah that's actually above me
do you think that's a deliberate thing or do you
think that's something that's happened by accident
you mentioned like the kind of people at Oxford
and capes yeah I think I think there's a problem
in my opinion with the culture of economics in
general which is that it's become the norm to
use these this complicated phrases complicated
words like acronyms people don't understand
um I think a big problem we have with economics is
that there's basically two odds of Economics which
is this sort of public phase and economics like
media journalism Central Banking or the bank of
England and then there's the financial markets if
you go in the financial markets everybody's just
you have to be right all the time and you get
rewarded very aggressively if you're right but
then in this public world the incentives are such
the sort of speak a good game and sort of sound
smart and look smart so if you ask me you know
you get these people on the news talking about
economics the reality is they are not trying to
be right they're not rewarded for being right you
know at the beginning of the financial crisis
I put out articles in open democracy videos
of my YouTube saying after after code we're
going to see a massive cost of living crisis
and that was right at the same time you know Larry
Elliot had economics editor of the Guardian so
we're going to see a house price collapse you know
three years later where's the punishment for that
so ultimately these guys in the media they're not
trying to be right they're not rewarded for being
right and I think that's a big problem that's why
you get basically I had analysis unfortunately
that's uh yeah that's really Rings true I think I
think a lot of people at all will be singing you
know that that's exactly their experience of it
you know we're told all these things like as if
as if there's some like tremendous all cni that
will understand the the economics of the country
at the same time they're getting it wrong every
single time guaranteed to get it wrong every
single time so I'm going to firstly let's come
to Sarah because we'll be just there sorting out
a couple of issues there with their Gary's mate
um Sarah the cost of living crisis what are you
seeing for your members so let's talk about like
what is the reality on the ground because I have
a fear that we haven't seen the worst of it but
we are starting to see some real negative effects
on people and how they live their lives so what
are you seeing what are you getting reported to
you through your membership so if I take you
back to last year so before we'd even kind of
fully got into this cost of living crisis we
surveyed our members around their access to
food through the pandemic so our members in the
main worked throughout the whole of the pandemic
you know producing Foods selling food when we
got the results back from the survey 40 of them
um were eating enough because they didn't have
enough food to eat one in five actually ran out
of food between paydays 35 were eating less so
the kids could have enough to eat um we've got
seven and a half percent that had become fully
reliant on food banks and one in five were using
friends and family to support them to provide
them food so they could feed themselves and
the families that was before you know the cost of
petrol rocket aired the the energy prices went up
if we run that now you know I know that those
figures would be double what they were back then
and we'd have more respondents and it it's just
catastrophic we've got members that are telling
us that they're doing extra shifts at McDonald's
just so they can have a free meal whilst they're
there because otherwise there wouldn't be eating
at all we've got members that you know have
anonymously told us that they're actually pinching
food from work so that they can can go on and try
and create something that's now that's we're
still in kind of the my dad never used to let
us put the eating on until the end of October
it was quite tight being a Yorkshire man but
people haven't had to put their eating on
after because they've been in such warm weather
Our concern is when we get to a point where people
are thinking right I need to rank up the heating
now the bills are going to fire up what's going to
happen we know there are millions of children in
poverty that have got working parents and the
reality for many of our members is they don't
know they're going to afford to get to work to do
work to then pay the bills that they need to pay
um and it's heartbreaking because these are
people like I say that we're working through the
pandemic celebrated as key workers but aren't
paid enough to be able to feed themselves in
the families yeah we had a we had a big thing
like um our local MP um in Sedgefield was uh
you know he was he was saying about how much he
supported key workers and he was out clapping on
his doorstep and making a big deal of it but at
the same time he was bought through legislation
that meant that people who were earned under a
certain amount of money were considered to be law
skilled workers well which is a is a key workers
or is it law skilled you know like these things
a lot of the time it doesn't mean low skilled
at all they defined it by low pay I think all
jobs out there have an element of skill about them
you know you can think about any job that's going
I've done all sorts of different jobs I've been a
cleaner at one point in my life I'll tell you what
I didn't have the skills necessary for that it was
really really hard I was not very good at it but
um I tried my best and I would love to see some
of these MPS like make 65 Sandwiches an hour at
Greg's I'll put cherries on the top of a Bakewell
tart they just wouldn't be able to do it that's
deemed as a law skilled job but it isn't otherwise
everybody would be able to do it absolutely
absolutely agree um and along with this so all
those things that you've heard there Gary you know
we've been told that this is because of what's
going on in Ukraine and this is because Global gas
prices have gone up and things like that I think
people are ready now because people understand
that that's a lie people understand that this was
happening before any conflict in Ukraine this was
happening anyway and I think people are ready for
the truth on this one now you said you predicted
this was going to happen so yeah firstly how did
you predict it and what do you think the cause
is of this like does that fit in with what you
predicted like I want to get the most important
thing like out straight out of the door because
this crisis is often spoken about in the media
like it's caused entirely by the war in Ukraine
um basically if it's called entirely by external
events almost like a natural disaster um if it
was a natural disaster everybody would be taking
some sort of pain the last two years have seen the
biggest and fastest ever increase in millionaire
and billionaire wealth in their history of this
country that's just a cold fact if you look at the
just the top 250 richest individuals in the
country they made 106 billion pounds increase
in their wealth in the first one year of Kobe so
the entire cost of the energy package is less than
100 billion pounds so we could pay for that if we
just tax the top 250 people enough to make them
as rich as they were before covert happened if
you broaden that if you were to tax the entire
wealthy class enough to make them as rich as they
were before covert started you could give every
single adult in the entire country 13 000 pounds
and this crisis would be over at the drop of a
head this is what drives me insane about what's
Happening Here politicians sit on the sofas of
BBC breakfast and they talk about it like it's
oh it's so terrible what's happened right if
you were to tax the rich enough to make them as
rich as they were three years ago you could give
every adult in the country 13 000 pounds so the
people watching what could you do with 13 000
this is not even every household every adult
this what drives me so crazy about this crisis
in unnecessary is does not need to happen this
is not it's not a natural disaster this is a
crisis of inequality listen if you if you have a
disaster like covid and in that disaster you allow
the biggest and fastest ever increasing inequality
to happen in your country you cannot be surprised
when it's immediately followed by the biggest
and fastest ever decrease in living standards for
ordinary families because that is what inequality
means you have made the rich richer and you have
made ordinary families significantly poor imagine
if the government came out and taxed every single
adult in the country 12 000 pounds and gave it
to the rich people would be up in arms but that
is what has happened and the reason I was able to
predict this is because at the very beginning of
covid you could see this happening you knew
straight away that things like furlough and
I'm not against furlough in any way you could see
straight away it was unbelievably expensive so you
have to ask two questions where's the money coming
from and where's it ending up nobody asked that
nobody asked that okay if the money's not coming
from the rich then it's coming from the taxpayer
okay so come and where's the money ending up okay
if you did not end up twelve thousand pound richer
somebody has your money and you could see from
the beginning of covert because during covid
ordinary families expenses did not decrease
significantly most ordinary families 70 80 90 of
their expensive expenses rent mortgage food bills
and those expenses did not disappear but if you
look at very rich families most of their spending
is luxury expensive holidays expensive restaurants
expensive bars going to the theater right all of
that stuff stops so during covid the spending of
very rich families collapse at 70 80 but a lot
of that spending pays the bills of all the no
families who work in those sectors so what you see
during covert is the rich stop spending and all
the new families stop receiving their incomes okay
so the government steps in and prints the money
gives it to ordinary families ordinary families
use it to pay their bills the owners of the assets
are the rich and they're not spending so in the
end 600 billion pounds from the government to the
rich that was predictable from the start of covet
so if you're that's 12 000 pounds per adult if
that all goes to top 10 you're talking about every
single adult and the top 10 making a hundred two
hundred grand pure cash so I'm asking you imagine
the government gave 100 200 Grand to every rich
person in the country of course you're going to
see inflationary crisis how much money is 100 200
grand for every single rich person in the country
this was so predictable in advance so painfully
predictable if the government is going to give out
600 billion pounds somebody has to do the analysis
of where does that money end up who benefits who
gets richer and nobody did it nobody the media
did it nobody in the labor party did it nobody the
bank of England did it nobody did it it's criminal
and then after that that enormous increase
amount of the rich you could you could tax
it back and you could solve this crisis what do
they do they slash taxes on rich people it's it's
I cannot I cannot believe what's happening and
and you know as somebody who has personally made
millions of pounds betting that if you smash an
equality through the roof you destroy the economy
and destroy a living standards for ordinary
people I know I'm not the person who's going to
get hurt by this but I can I know what's going
to happen down the line and it's going to be
you know I run a YouTube channel talking about
this stuff and when I saw happened yesterday I
was thinking is it even right for me to make a
video about this because maybe it's better that
people don't know because I cannot describe to you
how bad this is gonna you know I hear you talking
about this and and I wish I could tell you that
that was temporary and it's going to get better
but if you look at the policies this is going to
get significantly worse and it's this is me I'm
not you know I'm I'm a wealthy person I'm not the
one who's going to get hurt by this and it's it's
difficult for me to think about what's happening
so it's it's yeah it was predictable because you
could see from the beginning of Kobe we were
going to see a massive increase in inequality
and I think people need to understand given a ton
of money to rich people hurts you as an ordinary
family because it makes them it makes you poor
relative to them they get more resources you
get less resources that's what we're seeing
and it's so important people understand that
because if people don't understand that then the
government can do what they do and what we saw
yesterday and it's heartbreaking and it hurts
me to hear these stories yes I that's a pretty
bleak picture to be honest that you've you've just
painted there um it's for me the economy is broken
if that money is going straight to rich people
so they pump the money in at the bottom if the
economy is pumping that wealth straight to the
Top This trickle up system's not even trickled
up it's Rush your business it's like it's getting
pumped up absolutely exorbitant rate all the time
that's a broken economy and broken economies
need to be fixed with taxes you know you need to
be taxing money out from the wealthy people from
the wealthiest to give it to everyone else because
the economy is broken personally I'd rather
see that wealth circulated within a community
but the economy's still broken because we've got
so many massive corporations small businesses
going by the wayside like in my area there are
so many small businesses folding at the moment
and people say like you know the conservatives
are the party of business but they're not the
part of your small business there's a party
of massive massive companies and massive CEOs
you'll know a thing or two about CEOs won't
you Sarah how are the CEOs doing because I
know like I'm going to come under that weird weird
economic car crash that was the budget yesterday
um I'm going to come onto that shortly but like
you know shall we just check are the CEOs okay
in the industry do you think they're going to be
okay after all this yeah because they must have
been from that budget yesterday they must be
the ones in bother but like are they all right
I'd imagine so yeah I would imagine so although
you know if we could get some of our members and
and communities standing up and demanding better
you know um maybe they won't be you know I think
we should have a bit of a France element where
people are out on the streets you know and the
the conscious stops and I know we're probably
a long way from that but I'm kind of wondering
what it's going to take for people to do that you
know people talk about a general stripe I think we
need more than that though we need people out on
the streets saying we're not happy and we're not
having any more we want a new government because
nobody wants this trust now you're the person to
talk to you about this because I know the Bakers
Union have um kind of pushed back quite a bit on
this and we've seen a few victories and you
have organized now one of the things that's
very very difficult I think to organize amongst
Working Class People and amongst people who don't
have a lot of wealth is if they're going to take
action they've got to sacrifice a day's pay and a
day's pay could be the difference between them
eaten or not eaten and that is a huge thing if
you're going to withdraw your labor like remember
when the conservative party all went on strike
over Boris Johnson eventually when they realized
the writing was on the wall and they couldn't be
associated with these awful Behavior anymore
and they tried to Rebrand themselves again
they were able to go on strike they were able to
withdraw their labor from him because there was
no consequence they were still getting their MP
salary and things like that it's so easy to do it
if you don't have anything to risk and we've got
like I can't you I can't like go uh through this
without mentioning we've got Heather Woods sitting
over there Legend uh legend of the minor strikes
who kept people going during the minor strikes
in the 1980s uh which is absolutely brilliant
to see so you know how do you get people to take
those risks how do you support them in doing that
that must be a massive challenge for you in the
Bakers Union it is I mean we're quite a small
Union in comparison to some of the the larger
unions out there um but I think nobody chooses
to take strike action lightly you're right it's
a it's a lost day's worth of pay but I think it's
you can see with the the rising number of people
that are choosing to take strike action just how
pissed off people are I wasn't sure whether
I could swear then oh you can swear start for
a second and you can just see how pissed off
people are and how how they're just angry that
they're the people that have kept us going yet
the bosses that have stopped at home been safe
through a global pandemic or getting richer and
and they're still struggling to make ends meet
um and I suppose it comes to a Tipping
Point doesn't it you carry on as you are
struggling or you lose a day's pay and maybe
get something better at the end of it or you
you lose multiple days pay and get something
better and I think as trade unions we all try
and support our members you know we make sure
there's food on the picket lines we're not all
in positions where we can support our members
financially but we do everything that we can to
make sure that that picket line they're not you
know they're not being stabbed back into work
um and I think we're going to see more of that in
the coming months more workers are going to come
together you know but we're only six million
people and I say that we're only six million
people there are 18 million workers in the UK
that are in trade unions that are organizing their
workplaces and if I can I'll just do a little plug
because we're launching organized now today um at
3 15 and and that is designed to support these 18
million people that have got no idea what a trade
Union is no idea where to start organizing their
workplace make that first step because nobody else
is going to do it for us the Tories are out
they're not bothered they just want to make
the rich friends richer I can say this is a as a
general secretary of a disaffiliate a trade Union
but the labor party and Leadership aren't going to
do anything for us either workers and communities
are going to have to come together you're going
to have to stand together I'm going to have to
organize and demand better because that's the
only way that we're going to make change oh okay
um now I'm going to move on to that little budget
yesterday though it wasn't it was a mini budget
or something like that um I know that because
he wasn't allowed to get drunk while he did it
apparently because it wasn't a proper budget but
you're allowed to get drunk if you are doing a
budget one of these wonderful quirks we have in
our ridiculous parliamentary system at times so
um that came in yesterday now that was strayed
out of trickle down they aren't pretending anymore
one of the things that I would have loved to
have seen in the mainstream media is a comment
read that austerity was a lie so we've been
told for years and years that deficits are at
these awful things and you can never ever run a
deficit and you've got appeared back which is I
think economic nonsense because without deficits
then you don't have any money at all you know
like government government spending is public
sector wealth but it's where that money ends
up that's important they have made a conscious
Choice haven't they say right we are going to
put money into the pockets of the richest
people they're the ones who are struggling
whether or not they believe that that
wealth will genuinely trickle down
that has proved that austerity was a lie
austerity was done for no reason it was
something that was done to us to break down
working-class people to keep people in the
place and to make people's lives worse
to reduce the state to reduce Services
because they don't believe in services for
people is that a fair analysis or you know
have I have I entirely got it wrong because
what I saw was like tax cuts for rich people
um there were a few things in there like I would
have reversed the National Insurance rise to be
honest because that does affect people badly
although wealthier people benefited more from
from the reduction in that rise anyway like have
a have I got that wrong because I'm talking to an
economist about economics here so I'm starting I'm
starting to think maybe I better shut up so what
do you think Gary first one I encourage people to
talk about economics as much as they can because I
hate this space where ordinary people feel like
they're not allowed to speak about it because
ultimately the isolated economics at Oxford right
it's a bunch of rich people there talking about
things that are going to affect your lives so
let me know your opinions because ultimately
it's ordinary people who are on the front line of
this and who get hurt um for me what it shows is
the conservative party kind of pretended to be
ideological about austerity but if you actually
look at their behaviors but they appear to be
ideological about is increasing inequality because
they were anti-austerity uh sorry they were
anti-deficit when a deficit meant a welfare state
well-funded education system a welfare NHS well
funded local councils then they were anti-deficits
when deficits meant money to communities the
people the services that were anti-deficit
but when a deficit means tax cuts for the rich
tax cuts for Bankers then suddenly they're Pro
deficitly so I think and if you if you look at
what's happened to inequality in the last 15 20
years you know the conservative party happy to
move this way and that but they are consistently
massively increasing inequality and you know I
would encourage the labor party and people on the
left to come back and fight that by having a more
an understanding of the importance of wealth and
wealth distribution and who has it because whilst
we argue about whether a deficit is acceptable or
not we're losing our houses we're losing our
NHS we're losing our assets you know you know
I'm getting older now but people of my generation
and younger who can afford a house now who could
have I told you the people who can afford that
because look interest rates were not half percent
or some people don't need a mortgage because
they've got cash I've already told you the
average rich person accumulated 100 to 200
Grand cash in the last three years so now
we're in a situation where if you've got cash
which a lot of rich people do you can buy a
house if you're from an ordinary family
you want to buy a house with a mortgage
from your work you can't so I think we need to
we need to wake up and realize this wealthiest
important assets are important and we're
losing it and and they are getting it so
you know if we had that awareness then in the last
three years we would have been saying oh my God
how much is the wealth of the rich increasing in
the last three years how is that going to affect
us ultimately if the government gives cash to
rich people like it has been in the last three
years and now it's going to do again you know
cash is not like resources it's not like real
assets cash is what we use to distribute who gets
resources so the big problem here is when they
cut taxes ordinary families receive a small cut
in their taxes so maybe you're getting an extra
20 30 pounds a week and you're like happy days
I'm getting extra 30 pounds a week whereas the
rich guy down the road who's getting an extra
500 pounds a week you think you're richer But
ultimately money is how we distribute resources
so if you get a tiny bit of cash and the rich get
loads of cash you have more money but you will
get less resources less housing less food less
assets so don't allow yourself to be blinded by
a government which is happy to give you pennies
while it's giving the rich pounds because that
will give you more money and less resources
and nothing could make that clearer than what's
happened in the last three years the government
gets a lot of money up right and you know the
average amount accumulated was 12 000 pounds right
so an ordinary family you know that's not rich
Mark I've got three four thousand pounds three
four three four thousand pounds is a lot of money
so you're thinking you're winning but the rich got
200 Grand and then how and then house prices
double and the food price goes up 50 and the
energy price doubles and you're suddenly thinking
I thought I was richer but actually I'm poorer we
need to be smarter here we need to look who has
the wealth who has the assets and don't allow
ourselves to be blinded by Gifts of pennies from
a government that is actually robbing Us blind
um from that I keep on thinking as well that like
once you've got money money becomes like money's
expensive for poor people and it gives rich people
money so if once once rich people have a lot of
cash they can invest that or whatever they call it
they will speculate do all those things and that
money will then return more money to them if you
don't have much money um then you know your money
is expensive to get the the less money you have
the more expensive a loan is you know the the that
kind of thing really cause problem or you're on a
meter for your gas like I know that maybe a bigger
issue at the moment because the direct debits have
gone absolutely um you know crazy as well yeah
because the government has um slash taxes
rich people so much the financial markets have
massively increased interest rates in response
because they think it's going to be inflation
when interest rates are going to go up okay so
when the government slash taxes for rich people
the rich get richer when interest rates go up it's
easy to think that hurts everybody but it doesn't
when interest rates go up it hurts people who have
debts and it benefits people who have money okay
and who has debts that's ordinary families
with mortgages and it's the government who
has debt okay but we know that the average Rich
individual has increased their cash by 100 to 200
000 pounds in the last few years so they are
going to make a ton of money for this so the
government in giving money to rich people has
pushed the interest rates up which means that
ordinary families will pay more money every single
month to rich people it's it's it's a disaster
it's a disaster policy every single thing that's
happening is more money out of the pocket ordinary
families ordinary workers Ordinary People and into
the pocket of the rich the super rich who I will
add again have never increased their worth more
quickly than they have in the last three years
yeah it's been a long enough for you because it is
um but one of there were two things that stood out
one not necessarily cost a living crisis related
which was this new legislative bill that's going
to make sure that an employer can put in a crap
pay offer and then trade unions have got a ballot
it that we know that that's just an attack
on kind of the rmt and and the CWU and unite
um because of the last few months and
and the strikes that have been happening
um but the other thing that came out was about um
Universal Credit claimants I've got to apply for
more and better paid jobs or they'll get penalized
I might have read that wrong but that was kind of
the gist of what I've got I mean how disgusting
is that not only are people being pushed further
into poverty because they've got to wait longer
to get the benefits that they need to survive
that aren't enough anyway but they're going to
be penalized if they don't get a better paid
job but actually most jobs these days that are
easy to get a minimum wage so they're going to
be penalized for getting a minimum wage job that
they're going to lose out on the benefits anywhere
but some guy that's you know earning 80 a thousand
pound a year just from being an MP has decided
that they're not working hard enough so they need
it just that that's why I didn't watch it all
yesterday because I would have sat here and ranted
people earning more than 100 exactly as well so
the people that aren't going out and worrying
about how the feed in the family are you know
they're just with the fancy yachts and the big
houses are getting even more money and the people
that are literally scraping by I've got to do more
it just uh it was a difficult day from yesterday
and I know I know I'm not the person who's going
to be affected by it right but are people going to
accept this I've helped I really did they think
they're going to get away with it and you know
I I hope people won't I hope people won't but a
friend of mine called me up and he said the same
thing he's like well if I'm going to get 20 30
pounds a week maybe my Mick's going to be happy
about that and this is what we need to this is
why we need to educate and let people understand
you know 12 years ago there's a pandemic
that we've just been through people have
lost loved ones whilst they've been partying
yeah and I think for a lot of people and this
is why I'm talking about organizing and stuff
because they don't know what to do there's no
light at the end of the tunnel you know
things have been [__] for a long time
um and it's up to kind of us to say a lot there
is better yeah we've got to come together you've
got to dig deeper we've got to kind of build the
trenches so to speak because driving this morning
here and I dropped my partner off in town and
we saw on this guy on the street and he went you
know what in the next few months we're gonna see
Mama that aren't we and and we are because you're
right there's no end to this but we've got to do
stuff it's to me it's it's about telling stories
and the problem is for years and years and years
we've been told a story that individualism is good
that people deserve what they get people you know
people who work harder rewarded people who don't
work harder the people who end up on the street
and and that is not reality like neoliberalism
is the ideology that hates itself you know it's it
says that you know within the neoliberal ideology
they talk about the natural rate of unemployment
don't they they need an unemployed body of people
in order to ensure that the wages of ordinary
people are kept down so that they can say right we
can go on in like an unemployed person will come
and get your job and yet they're hid unemployed
people now I would argue that unemployed people
are in the public sector there appears to be an
employee to keep keep wages down you know that's
the that's the whole point of them that's their
ideology but they won't admit it and then they go
after unemployed people and say actually you're
doing something wrong and people internalize that
and they believe that and everyone like they're
looking around they're looking at their next door
neighbor or something like that saying oh do you
think he's got a couple more quid than me or I'm
working harder than him and I deserve more rather
than looking at the at the top of the hill at the
castle you know the metaphorical castle of like
these people with super yachts that you know they
are the the people who are taking the wealth from
our society taking the money taking that 12 000
pounds out of the puppets of every single person
in the country and I think the the stories that
you've both told today I think they're incredibly
important that they go out to a mainstream
audience how do we get them out to a mainstream
audience because you know what today it's going to
be absolutely brilliant I'm going to be speaking
to people who believe what I believe I'm here with
comrades today but there are people out there who
won't be getting this message how do we get to
those how do we change those stories do you think
Sarah I'm going to come to you because you speak
to these ordinary people all the time in your job
we've got to talk to everybody haven't we
I said I was at South Yorkshire Festival a
few weeks ago and I said two things one of the
things was trust will get in and it'll be worse
than we've ever seen before she'll make that
she'll look like a lib Dem because she's got
a purpose she's got to make up for boris's
feelings and and she's gonna wit the ground
um and I miss running because she did um and
the second thing was that we've got to talk
to people we've got to get back into there a bit
of talking to people anybody and everybody about
about the realities of life not what's being
told on the right-wing media because if you're
told something often enough for long enough you
believe it don't you and that's what we've had
in this country the right-wing media that's
Friends of the billionaires telling us that
you next door neighbor that don't go to work to
Shaker and the the Polish couple across the road
are immigrants stealing me jobs and that's
what people believe and we've got to go out
and and spread the narrative that that's not
right we're all in this together they're not
not everybody's going to agree with us and
some conversations will be bloody difficult
because they'll be right-wing you know they'll
they'll be forage supporters and and worse
but there will be there there will be the most
meaningful conversations because if we can get
them to understand then we will start to see
change but until we start going outside of our
own Echo Chambers and talking to other people
and engaging in those conversations nothing's
going to change because we'll just keep talking
to each other yeah what is this this space of
individualism right I know it's used against us
but look it is becoming clearer and clearer and
clearer that what is happening is not working for
the vast majority of individuals you know this
is you know for a long time it was people towards
the poor end of the spectrum who are getting hurt
that's not true anymore look what is happening
now you know if you are bang in the middle exactly
average financial situation you are getting hit
you are getting seriously seriously hit and you
know I always think about you know who are the
people who are supporting the conserving fight you
know and a lot of the voters are older people you
know and a lot of older people especially property
owning older people up to some degree protected
by their house prices going up I want to find ways
to reach out to those people to say listen okay
I know you're protected by house price going up
where your kids going to be what your kid's lives
going to be like what your grandkids lives going
to be like you know what I mean I think we need
to find the fact is this is not working and and
it's Madness and if we live in a society where
people are thinking me and my family well then
we should win because me and my family has been
destroyed financially for 70 80 of the country
here so let's find ways to reach those people
and communicate them and say listen this isn't
working for me this isn't working for you maybe
this doesn't maybe we don't agree on absolutely
everything but we should have a big majority of
the country here who should say look we can it's
obvious it's obvious 70 80 of the country are
being driven down house ownership is collapsing
levels of debt are rising to the roof and at the
same time the fastest ever increasing wealth of
the super rich there is a massive opportunity
here to build a coalition based purely on people
whose Financial lives are being smashed you know
what I mean I think we need to find ways to reach
those people and you know I'm going to use the
opportunity to plug my YouTube channel that I did
there is that everyone is allowed in everyone is
allowed then and all it is about explaining that
to people look you're being hit I'm being hit and
you know the media is going to try and find ways
to divide us old versus young men versus women
different ethnicities North versus the South okay
and look there are everybody's problems need to
be recognized but I also need to recognize that
we're all getting hit so we need to be able
to come together above that and look at the
speed with which people's economic lives are being
hurt so I think there's a massive opportunity here
if we can it's building community and building
those relationships you know speak to the people
around you and say that we're all getting hit here
I know we don't agree on everything but this is
serious and and you are going to see a massive
acceleration decrease in living standards so
we take the opportunity to bring people together
and say look we really need to create some Unity
fight back and yeah find spaces and ways to do it
brilliant and I hope people at home are clipping
this and uh and they're going to put out little
clips of this and share that this with people
because that's a nice way to do it as well we've
just had some great explainers here from you as
as panelists um about what the problems are what
the solutions are is going to come next so we've
got a few minutes left to talk about what those
Solutions are so like I guess Sarah what would
you like to see coming in the next I don't know
from the next government from from the labor party
at the moment what sort of offer are you seeing
because at the moment like they've been very very
tentative about whether they'd even um oppose that
could in the 45 rate of tax they've been very Coy
about that and I'm like I think that's a that's
an easy one for me yes of course we oppose that
um you know and I'll go a lot further with a
lot more wealth but like you know what would
you like to see from the next Parliament
so we we've got some clear clear demands
um from the next Parliament we want to see
the minimum wage raise to 15 pounds an hour
um for all workers regardless of age you know you
don't get a discount on nappies if you're a mum at
17 because you're 17 you shouldn't have a discount
on your age when you're doing the same job
an outright ban on Zero's contracts how can you
even begin to look at getting a mortgage or rent
or even a bloody mobile phone on a contract if you
don't know what I was going to work from one week
to an X we want sick pay at 100 from day one so
if you are unfortunate enough to be ill you can
still afford to pay your bills and that's less
stress on you than just having to rely on less
than 100 pound a week um what else and a right
to food for everyone and part of that includes
free School meals for all children up until the
age of 18 and that might sound kind of radical
but if you've got to go to school until you're 18
because that's what the law says they should feed
you whilst you're there and that again would
release some disposable income because you're
being paid 15 pounds an hour um to be able to
spend in the local economy and it would make
a difference because it'd be normal people that
have got that money not not the rich billionaires
um do I think it's going to happen I think I might
be thinking Pie in the Sky with the labor party
but that's why what we would like to see and we've
seen over the last couple of years that that money
can be spent you know and it should but it should
be spent on working people and and our communities
are not giving billions to dodgy companies that
aren't going to do what they say they're going
to do yeah I always say them you know give them
money to give money to someone who works in a shop
or a builder or something like that it's going
to get spent a nurse a teacher they'll spend
their money give it to a billionaire and ends up
in the Cayman Islands you know and that's what
the government have just done but at least they
can't say to us if they were sitting here now
they would have absolutely no leg to stand on for
saying how are you going to pay for that because
they have just paid out of public money for a
huge huge increase in wealth of the wealthiest
never again will we accept that argument that
they that you know how you're going to pay for
this it's it's absolute nonsense Gary what do you
think what would you like to see well I was too
busy looking at the markets and the economics of
yesterday to release the labor response if they
have if they're not opposing that they're cutting
the 45 rate I'm very disappointed to hear that
um but if they're not going to do it we have to
do it and um we have to explain to people how
this is going to affect them we have to explain
we have to make it as clear as possible clear
explanations that Reach people look if you allow
the rich to get richer if you allow inequality to
increase a massive rate that hurts you your family
your kids ability to buy houses your ability to
put food on the table your ability to heat your
home you are in a competition for resources with
the very rich and if we give a ton of money to
them and a bit of money to you you'll get hurt
we need to explain that to people I think that is
if I think if people understood what the future
held for them and their families economically they
would not accept it 70 80 90 of this country would
not accept it so we need to find ways to explain
that to them to cross the divide and then and then
the labor party would have to move because if
people understood the importance of inequality
and of wealth inequality the importance of wealth
wealth inequality to them and their families they
would demand of the labor party do something about
wealth inequality and they would have to do it so
you know I always ask what can I do you know if I
can explain to people how serious it is for their
lives their future their family's future that we
do something about inequality they would demand
of the politicians and then whoever's in charge
they have to move because if the people insist
it then the politicians have to give it so I say
communicate to people clearly to your friends to
your family you know I always say my YouTube tell
your friends tell your families what's happening
if people understood it they wouldn't accept it
and I think that is the way that we can do it
about future so brilliant thank you to both of you
so I believe that we are coming to the close of
the show now is that right people yeah yeah next
segment coming up very very soon uh there's a very
very special guest coming but don't forget to keep
your super chats coming in because one of the ways
that we can communicate with people is through the
world transformed through Gary's YouTube channel
join us Gary's economics join uh join a union
as well whether that's the biggest Union whether
that whatever industry that you're in whatever
profession that you're in or if you if you are
one of those people who are employed by the state
not the work um then you know join unite Community
or someone like that you know there is a trade
Union for you uh also subscribe to socialist Think
Tank and uh the world transformed as well and make
sure you get those super chats coming in because
the people at World transformed are doing so much
good and so much to educate people to help people
and you know they deserve a lot of support let's
show them the solidarity we have someone coming
in you know I don't even know who it is do it do
we know who it is yet someone very very special
is coming in so I'm going to hand you over to Dan
thanks very much to Gary Round of Applause please
and Sarah we've been socialist Think Tank
enjoy the rest of the world transformed